al franken's book lies in the lying
liars who tell them is now in its 12th
week on the New York Times nonfiction
bestseller list he talked about it
recently at the University of Missouri
now we originally planned to pair this
program with Bill O'Reilly talking about
his bestseller who's looking out for you
however mr. O'Reilly refused to allow
book TV to cover his event last week in
Long Island al franken is just under two
hours
welcome ladies and gentlemen my name is
James page I'm with the Department of
Student Activities Special Events
Committee here at the University of
missouri-columbia thank you
tonight we are proud to present a man
was spent 15 years as a writer and
performer for Saturday Night Live he's
written numerous new york times
bestsellers among them Rush Limbaugh is
a big fat idiot
and his current book lies and the lying
liars who tell them
he's also a five-time Emmy Award winner
a Grammy Award winner and a Minnesota
native
he's also wanted me to tell you that
he's been married for 28 years and has
two wonderful kids
so ladies and gentlemen without any
further ado please give a big round of
applause for mr. Al Franken
thank you thank them
thank you thank you it's great to be
here thank you James for the kind
introduction here at Mizzou at a young
Republican come up to me at a book
signing earlier said they'll really like
it if you say it's great to be here at
Mizzou
he couldn't fool me this is a great
school has a incredible School of
Journalism one that I understand teaches
that total objectivity is is impossible
but it's so important to be fair and
balanced more about that later how many
here have read lies and line wires raise
your hand okay it makes a great gift
it's a great gift well a couple weeks
ago the Congress approved the 87 billion
dollar package for for Iraq and pretty
much had to support our troops and you
know it's funny during the 2,000
campaign when George W Bush said that he
was against nation building I didn't
realize he meant only our nation
this president will be the first
president since herbert hoover who has
not created one new net job in his first
term we've lost almost three million net
jobs net is important I saw Don Evans
the Commerce Secretary on some show the
other day and said we've created a lot
of jobs we've just lost more in fact if
you put the two Bush bushes together
Bush one bush two in there almost now
seven years of their presidencies they
have not created one new net job now
numbers do not lie ladies and gentlemen
if you extrapolate from that of the
bushes had been president had run this
country from it's very inception to the
present day not one American would have
ever worked
we would be hunter-gatherers
Bill Clinton during his eight years 22
to 23 million jobs new net jobs created
I saw Clinton a while back talked to the
Council on Foreign Relations he spoke
from just a few notes spoke for a couple
hours
in great depth and breadth of detail it
made me miss him but
but in fairness to President Bush there
is more to being president than simply
being articulate intelligent and
knowledgeable language is not this
president's strong point you remember
when he first started using evildoers
that the rest of the administration felt
that they had to use evildoers too so
every day honoree fleischer was you know
make it sound like was an actual word or
something so every day like Ari
Fleischer would be going like well the
evildoers are do evil and they're very
evil and we're going to try to stop them
from doing the evil and evil they're
evil doers they even do is that's what
we're doing we're getting and so and you
expect that from Ari Fleischer Ari
Fleischer is a chimp but
well what was really fun was watching
like Cheney try to work evildoers in the
was always like this is not a war
against Islam this is an effort to
eradicate the evildoers
and remember when we first started the
war against terrorism remember when
President Bush referred to it as a
crusade that that was smart and then and
and first the operation in Afghanistan
was called operation called it operation
infinite justice my feeling at the time
was is that the Karl Rove should have
just been gone out in the streets of
Washington flag down a cab got in a
Pakistani cab driver and and brought him
in the White House and just run this
stuff by him first no
operation infinite justice oh no no no
no please do not call it that do not
call it that please no only Allah can
bestow infinite justice please please
please do not call it that no but what
else what else you got crusade oh no no
who's the idiot who thought of that oh
no
remember when don rumsfeld used to hold
a lot of press conferences and and he
got high points for his for his press
conferences but I I noticed one thing I
don't know if you noticed this but when
he was ever whenever he's on run selves
on thin ice he would start doing this
thing where he'd ask himself rhetorical
questions and then answer them it was
always like are we going to be the
target of another terrorist attack sure
you bet
are there going to be massive casualties
yeah do we know when and where not a
clue could it be a plane flying into a
nuclear reactor sure some plutonium in a
in a reservoir that'd yeah that do am I
giving the terrorists ideas they
wouldn't otherwise have maybe I don't
know
great administration we use sent us
maybe the best our Attorney General well
come on come on come on it's a little
nuts hey
by nine that sounds harsh but um I think
I can prove it man you know how the and
I'm not talking about the Crisco the
anointing himself which is that's what
that's weird that's weird I'm talking
about the Attorney General when he gives
his press conferences does from the
Great Hall of Justice and in the Justice
Department and behind him he has a
podium and they're behind him is the
spirit of Justice it's a woman it's a
statute of a woman and the statue has a
bare boob as a boob to bare breasts it's
a boob and boy he just could not stand
being photographed with a bare boob
behind it I guess he just didn't want to
stand in front of another boot there
wasn't he just did not want it so and I
did what does that say about him I mean
how does Johnny does john ashcroft like
let's say goes to vacation in Rome I
mean does he walk around with an
erection the entire time what what does
this mean so he spends eight thousand
dollars draping the boob you know I have
another better idea on how to spend the
money use it to fight terrorism
but Bush not great with language
although I sometimes I think he was
smarter than we thought remember during
a campaign he said he didn't mind being
misunderestimated and we heard that we
heard that and we thought hey he's
stupid he's a stupid stupid man but I
don't think so i think he was
outsmarting us i think what he meant by
that was I don't mean mind being
underestimated for the wrong reason say
say I think he wasn't just stupid I
think he was it turns out we know now he
was dishonest for example and and this
all this myth about the liberal press
and I deal with this in the book and I
used the first debate as an example the
first presidential debate in which Gore
said they had gone down to Texas to with
FEMA to a disaster with FEMA director
James Lee wit and it turns out he didn't
go to that disaster with James Lee wit
he went with James Lee wits deputy he
went to 17 other disasters during the
clinton-gore administration's but that
one he went with a deputy of James Lee
wit but the press jumps all over them
it's as if James Lee wit is the most
popular man in America and gore was
lying just to get some of that James Lee
wit magic to rub off on
article after article in the same debate
Bush said and he said this repeatedly
said repeatedly during the campaign he
said by far the vast majority of my tax
cuts go to those at the bottom that's a
quote he said that many times in the
debate about his tax cuts he said by far
the vast majority of the help goes to
those at the bottom by far the vast
majority my tax cuts goes to those at
the bottom now as you know the bottom 60
60 percent got fourteen point seven
percent of that tax cut now this is a
more significant miss statement then I
went down to a fire with James Lee wit
don't you think nothing nothing from the
press now is it because the press has
this huge conservative bias I don't
think so i think the press at that point
just thought he doesn't know
leave the man alone he doesn't know he
doesn't know but he did he knew he knew
and I think when he misled us about why
we went to war in Iraq he knew in state
of the union address when he said that
the British had learned that Iraq had
attempted to buy large quantities of
uranium from Africa he knew that wasn't
true the British can't learn something
that isn't true by the way if there's
anything in my book it turns out to be
wrong as its I got it from British
intelligence
and
now already found one that's kind of
embarrassing on page 245 I say that that
sean hannity from from fox fox
commentator lived up newt gingrich's but
from 1994 to 1998 I got we got that from
British intelligence and sorry it turns
out that Hannity only took residence up
gingrich's but in early 95 so I
apologize to that you got to admit when
you make a mistake you gotta admit when
you make a mistake I before the war I
was very torn like so many Americans
I've watched every everyone's talking
about I read as much as I could my
father I saw Kissinger for example on
Charlie Rose and got one thing I got to
say about Kissinger he's getting a
little harder to follow and listen to as
he gets a little older but I thought it
was a little like this it was like Ben
Johnny the President must make the case
at the tapas as his weapons of mass
destruction
while at the same time laying Bradford
within the international community that
his weapons pose an imminent threat and
in the event of a raven like you're
getting sleepy at least a pass out but
he was right the President had to make
the case that Saddam possessed weapons
of mass destruction which posed an
imminent threat and lay that groundwork
within the international community and
so they did you know it is one thing and
I'm going on my fourth USO tour next
month I can't and that's what's say
where I'm going no no it's uh it's my
honor my honor I'm actually not supposed
to say where I'm going I'm going I'm
going to Greenland
this time of year it's very depressing
up there
watching for Soviet missiles missiles
coming anyway I'm well I'm going there
because well anyway wherever I'm going
and I love doing it and I got to say
it's one thing for a president to lie
about his sex life it's another thing
for present lie about why he is sending
our men and women into battle
this
this is serious this is serious stuff
and Americans have to start asking some
hard questions what did the president
know and if not why didn't he know it if
as may be the case the President did not
understand his intelligence briefings
did he ask to have them explained to him
and did he know that he didn't
understand them these are questions that
must be asked repeatedly and in an
accusatory tone
so I was saying what a great School of
Journalism this is I've been asked by a
student to discuss tonight the lawsuit
from Fox against against me into trying
to and and my publisher doesn't trying
to suppress the book I'll tell the story
of it it it's I love it's a great story
to tell and you'll really enjoy it
you'll get a kick out of it and i really
i really enjoy telling the story it's
great ok it it started at the end of may
I was in Los Angeles to do the thing
called The Book Expo where authors tell
booksellers who are having a convention
about the books are coming out in the
fall and I was on a panel with mount the
great Molly Ivins and with
with Bill O'Reilly no no no not mine and
with an me and and we were there too you
know uh Molly is promoting her her book
bushwhack great book bill was promoting
his book living with herpes
you know it's a very good book very good
book it's a lesson there for any writer
right from your experience I'm at saugus
and and I was plugging you no lies and
lying liars who tell them no fair and
balanced look at the right and O'Reilly
did not like the fact that his his
picture is on the book that has the
words lies and lying liars on it so
Somali spoke first and then it was
bill's turn and he decided to kind of go
after me and he said things like I don't
I don't call people liars I don't do
that kind of thing now evidently he's
never watched his own show
and evidently he didn't realize this
wasn't his show because I got to
actually get up and talk and after him
so I really felt that I owed bill an
explanation of why he was on a book
called wise and lying liars who tell
them so I didn't explain it using mainly
suffering the book of mainly Nexus
transcripts just stuff in the public
record and proved that he was not just a
liar but well you know kind of a
pathological liar and um and bill didn't
like it and everyone else seemed to be
enjoying it it was really except for
Bill and so he said shut up you've had
your 35 minutes not shut up which was
interesting because I had spoken for a
little lesson 20 he couldn't even tell
me to shut up without lying it was
really it was an interesting thing so
so they got very mad and and that was a
Friday I believe in the next time he did
the raid his radio show on Monday he
said if this had happened in the Old
West we would have had to have had a
shootout
I thought that was interesting and but
the most interesting thing was that he
guaranteed to his radio audience that he
would have won the shootout 150 years
ago when we had our shootout and I found
that very instant he could guarantee to
his audience and and you know and a lot
of you probably don't know this but it
was very odd me because during the
summers I do the whole state fair
quick-draw circuit and
yeah i'm i'm like third in the country
and i know and i know bill ain't first
or second
so so I was I was you know intrigued
that he could guarantee that and he said
he said and this is a quote he said I
would have shot Franken between the head
said that
so he was mad and see a thing about
O'Reilly he's like a bully and my dad
always told me to stand up to bullies
and he's like the kid in the school he
already hit sack idiots another kitty
it's a whole bunch of kids the kid hits
him you go talk to the teacher teacher
sue him so about a week later my
publisher received a letter from Fox
threatening to sue us if we didn't take
off his picture and fair and balanced
their trade trade mark this is it was a
lot of irony in this whole thing and so
my publisher actually was kind of a
little nervous about this and she called
me up and was kind of upset and she said
you know Bethel I said don't worry look
I've been doing this for 30 years and I
can tell you that satire is protected
speech even if the object of the satire
doesn't get it
I said our letter to Fox should be dear
Fox please please please sue us and I
made my publisher feel better and she
got she got the best First Amendment
lawyer in the country to Floyd Abrams
that he read their letter and said
there's no problem here and he sent them
back a letter he didn't send him the
police please please letter he sent he
sent the deer fox this is the United
States of America left
so
so I figured we're and that was it i
knew that i just said they're not going
to they're not gonna do this uh they did
I went on vacation found out I was in
Italy I found out I with my family and
we I was woken up by someone in the
house so now you're being sued by Fox
and I went well I said good and I went
back to sleep I'm not getting you and
then I got up a couple hours later and I
got on my email I started getting stuff
from team Frank and the students at
Harvard that help help them research the
book and they're all going like isn't
this great and they knew and and I
checked amazon we were like shooting up
you could you when went at number one on
amazon only 12 hours and we were in
Italy just going they're suing up
fox is suing us so um and it goes to
court we go to court we have a hearing
and they were literally laughed out of
court now usually when you say someone
was literally laughed out of court what
you really mean is they were
figuratively laughed out of court no no
not here they were literally laughed out
of court people came from miles around
to be in the gallery of the court this
federal courtroom and to see this great
First Amendment case and and then the
case was that that I had violated and
see I didn't even know what it was about
their trademark fair and balanced and I
didn't know whether it was that we had
simply violated their trademark by
putting in the subtitle or that I had
violated or I had stolen their idea of
using fair and balanced ironically I
thought maybe that was it
you stole our joke sorry Joe so so the
Fox attorney starts off this is her
first words our mouths arguing the case
is your honor the fox news channel has
over 85 million subscribers and the
judge says I don't know what that means
I get cable does that mean I'm a fox
news subscribe
and the Fox attorney said yes the whole
quorum just burst in the laughter and
the rest of the 20 minutes or it was
just laughter through the whole thing
she was like she was in a lawyer's
nightmare it was like it was it was like
a miracle she was not in her underwear
this woman and an employed made our case
and then the judge judge said I'm gonna
go to why don't my chambers and I'll
come back with a decision and it was
like this
an expense
and he looked at the Fox attorneys and
said you know there are hard cases and
there are easy cases this is an easy
case your case is wholly without merit
both legally and factually and it is
very unlikely that fair and balanced is
a valid trademark and so Fox as soon as
they could withdrew the case their case
route obviously the my book wasn't
enjoying and was allowed to be published
and and fox with druid media leak so
they didn't so because the next thing
would have been you know Fox stripped of
its trademark and so and I don't know if
you know if you watch Fox and I would
not recommend it but you notice they do
not use fair and balanced anywhere where
you know near as much as they used to
because you know is it kind of
embarrassing and I but I think the judge
may have inadvertently given them their
new slogan the Fox News Channel wholly
without merit
now the fox news channel like the other
parts of the right-wing media the wall
street journal editorial page talk radio
rush limbaugh also from the state no no
I may be doing a radio show and we're
going to try to do drug free radio it's
going to be an experiment I don't know
if it can be done you're going to try to
do that and the washington times in the
New York Post and books like you know
Ann Coulter's books and yeah and all the
regular ebooks there you know shells for
the Republican Party for the
conservatives and now for the Bush
administration and so I want to read you
something I keep my back pocket here
from britt hume on august twenty sixth
about well i'll just read it from his
grapevine segment of the show this is a
quote says 277 US soldiers have now died
in iraq which means that statistically
speaking US soldiers have less of a
chance of dying from all causes in Iraq
than citizens have of being murdered in
California which is roughly the same
geographical size
the most recent statistics indicate that
California has more than 2,300 homicides
each year which means about 6.6 murders
each day meanwhile our US troops have
been in Iraq for 160 days which means
they are incurring about 1.7 deaths
including illness and accidents each day
well yeah but the most recent statistics
also indicate there are 34 million
people living in California and that we
now have a hundred and thirty-three
thousand troops in Iraq which would
actually make it like about 65 times
more likely that a soldier in Iraq would
be killed and for everyone who's killed
five are made so this was pointed out to
brit hume by the washington post and he
said this admittedly it was a crude
comparison
but it was illustrated of something
and I agree
and I happen to be at a Dean rally and I
was by the way i'll talk about this
later I've done rallies for Dean and
forget part and the great guy great man
for I'm doing for John Kerry and 44
Wesley Clark I just the idea is I'm
helping them all raise money so they can
run negative ads against each other I
think that it's a good plan I don't know
what I'm doing anyway so I read this at
a Dean rally and and you know I got to
the point where he says a luster tip of
something I said yeah it's illustrative
of how big a and then I use the word i
shouldn't have used it's synonymous with
poop chute
I said how big a poop shoot britt hume
is and how effing shameless he is and
how effing shameless foxes they're
effing shameless and so I was and I was
man and I don't apologize for getting
angry when someone trivializes the
danger that our soldiers are operating
under in Iraq
so Riley gets his footage from the Dean
rally and starts it with me saying yeah
Brit Hume is a poop chute poop chute and
he's effing shameless and Fox is effing
shameless and their effort you know and
he runs that and goes like this guy's
nuts it's wrong with this guy say it's
crazy so Oh Riley goes on his booked
when he starts bringing it everywhere so
he brings it to the view to the ABC show
the view you know with Barbara Walters
and the women and and he brings and
shows it there and go see you this guy's
crazy and and I did the view later and
explained it but the producer for the
view told me that he called the guy he
got the footage from at Fox and said
what did I'll say right before this and
the guy from Fox said oh it didn't make
any sense
so Riley does everyone know about the
Terry Gross interview the fresh air
interview so Riley walked off the show
because he was asked very tough
questions did you just very tough
question you know when you come on this
factor you're in the no spin zone you're
gonna ask the tough questions the dude
is miku text later so Terry asked him so
this is about in context so she asked
about this interview he did with with
Jeremy Glick they write about in the
book Jeremy's father died at the World
Trade Center and Jeremy signed a
petition against the war in Iraq and had
some I have lefty things to say and
O'Reilly was very surprised that someone
whose father died at the World Trade
Center would sign this petition and had
Jeremy on his show and Jeremy said some
some things on the show that got him mad
like that Bush the elder had funded help
fund the Mujahideen you know true stuff
and so he told Jeremy to shut up shut up
get the transfer it sound familiar
and then and kick the kid off the show
unplugged the microphone and then
accordingly neglect and this is written
in Harper's said and actually O'Reilly
hasn't denied this we said to the kid
get the F out of here or all effing tear
you to pieces okay so Terry Gross asked
them about this and goes like did you
read the transcript and Terry civil I
read the transcript and Harper's ah now
that's the left-wing media they take
things out of context if you read the
whole transcript which is very readily
available which by the way it is you'll
see this kid asked some pretty
outrageous there said some pretty
outrageous things he said that Bush
President Bush and Bush to a one the
elder orchestrated 911 that's pretty
outrageous stuff so I was a reporter I
gotta ask him if he had any proof and he
didn't and that's defamation okay now in
writing my book I had read the
transcript and the kid didn't say
anything of the sort so I got a telegram
from from Jeremy and said a few things
to me he just wanted to say said I just
wanted to wish you well and let you know
how grateful I am that you address my
episode with a riling your book it's
very difficult to lose your dad in such
a violent fashion and even harder to
have your love for your family question
so abrasively by such right-wing hacks
as o'reilly and he goes on later he says
about a Riley says he has been defaming
me almost weekly at first he totally
blew off the episode but I figure he's
on the defensive because all the
negative press he's telling the press
that I said that Bush knew
about the World Trade Center and in the
cherry gross interview he says that the
Jeremy said that the bush one bush to
orchestrated it said we never I never we
never even gesture toward the question
of prior knowledge and anyway I don't
believe Bush knew this is obvious to
anyone who saw the episode or read the
full transcript this is very damaging
for me I'm a PhD candidate and freelance
writer it doesn't help me to get gigs
being painted as some sort of conspiracy
nut now Riley has been saying over and
over and over again that I am a smear
merchant and I have been defaming him
and I have been asking him publicly as
much as i can to come up with one fact
about him in my book that isn't true and
he hasn't been able to he keeps saying i
doctored his photo
I didn't dr. his photo I talked to the
it was a public domain photo actually at
the book X well before we went on he
said that's that's a doctored photo I
said it isn't we got a public domain I
was going to dr i was going to d splotch
it
so that's a doc you know I look like
this I don't look like that I look like
this not that I said I i I'm sorry we
got it you know I said and I actually I
said I'd please get us a different
picture I get us a picture from the
factor something of you lying anything
with your mouth open would probably do
now which I thought would actually like
jolly him up or make him laugh as I
didn't I think it had the reverse effect
and but nevertheless I've talked to
people at Fox he said he had a skin
condition and that's what he looks like
that man you know that's what he looked
like at the time and the photographer
who took the picture confirmed to me
that so he looked like and we were going
to have the best d splotch ER in the
business d splotch him until he was just
such a jerk that I said okay just keep
it splotchy so he has not been able and
he keeps calling me this thing I miss
Muir merchant and I've defamed him and
he can't he doesn't come up with
anything and everything about him is
terminable he was said he was a
registered independent when he was
actually a registered Republican I mean
he said he grew up in levittown he grew
up in westbury actually levittown e you
know he has this image of himself as
this you know come working-class guy who
came from a hardscrabble background and
live in levittown that's working class
and well we got it from an inside source
that he didn't grow up and live it down
he grew up in westbury the inside source
was his mother
his dad was an accountant he made 35
thousand dollars in 1978 or something
which is the equivalent of like 90,000
now he was a middle-class guy it's okay
to be middle class and then I think but
he's got this thing and I asked method
at the Book Expo I said which was it
westbury or levittown I figure there's
no way to spin this there are two
different villages there to separate
different villages and he said I grew up
in the Westbury section of Levittown
which is like saying I you know I grew
up in Brooklyn the Manhattan section of
Brooklyn it's just so he's accusing me
all over the place of defaming him and
you know what I don't like it but I have
a platform you know I don't have his
platform and not on the air every day
but I have I at least have a platform
this kid doesn't this kid whose crime
was losing his father at the World Trade
Center all they have left of his dad is
his thumb and having different views
than Bill O'Reilly and if you check out
that transcript Jeremy Nevers had
anything like Bush one bush to
orchestrated 911 and I just want to use
this opportunity to give Jeremy
something of a platform because I
because we're on c-span
you're a great crowd everywhere I've
been going for this book amazing crowds
Nathan crowds I had two thousand people
yet sorry save Kansas State
that's in Manhattan Kansas not Brooklyn
Kansas but Manhattan Kansas we had 1,200
people in the Barnes & Noble in austin
texas everywhere overflowing crowds
standing room only and when that happens
and I've done a number of books it isn't
about just about the book it's about me
people
people just love me
no it isn't it is nothing something is
happening in this country the tide is
turning the tide is turn
and there is some anger in this country
and our friends on the rights they are
they're just butch bashing yeah and as
I've gone around the country it took me
about two thirds of the way through this
book tour I think to figure out where
the stems from and I may be one well
this is my theory and it comes from 911
because after 911 we had a unique moment
in the history as least as far as i know
of this country i was not around for
Pearl Harbor but all Americans came
together every one of us got behind the
president everybody got caught up
virtually everyone got caught up in the
patriotic fervor even people you never
expect a friend of mine I never would
have expected when right to his closet
got out his old America t-shirt it took
him about four hours to whiteout sucks
but he's never lies he got it
but Bush had this opportunity he had an
amazing opportunity to lead this nation
into a new American Century in a spirit
of mutual purpose and mutual sacrifice
when steady just hijacked it he just
hijacked it for his own political
benefit
two thousand two elections accuse
Democrats in the Senate of not caring
about our national security they ran ads
against Max Cleland who lost three limbs
in Vietnam with pictures of him next to
Saddam Hussein and Osama bin Laden
saying he doesn't have the courage to
lead this president has not asked anyone
who's affluent to sacrifice anything he
just during time of war ii just give him
bigger and bigger tax cuts to those of
us at the top I admit it
hasn't asked a thing of us maybe to stay
alert
you know the highest level we've reached
in the color thing is orange the orange
level alert which is the second highest
level of alert it's the highest level at
which you're still encouraged to go to
the mall and at read the president would
urge you to shop online
so we have these tax cuts these deficits
this President took a surplus and made
it in a record deficits he took a
surplus of goodwill around the world and
turn that into a deficit and who's
sacrificing well we're our troops are in
Iraq pretty much alone people on the
bottom we're going to get the vast
majority of the help our losing single
moms are losing Medicaid people are
losing jobs No Child Left Behind is the
most ironically named piece of
legislation
the most ironically named piece of
legislation since the nineteen forty two
japanese Family Leave Act
these Republicans they love iron the
clear skies initiative that evidently
the purpose is to clear the skies of
birds so I'm supporting all these
Democrats some people think it's a bad
idea for a comedian or especially
satirist to get behind specific
politicians I know this only too well
years ago the first politician I ever
did a fundraiser for was Pol Pot
a few years later I saw the killing
fields and I I gotta tell you I felt
like a schmuck but I'm I want to win
this election in a year and you one
thing I hope that they do one thing
that's going to take all of you one
thing I really hope they do is run the
footage I hope the Bush campaign runs
the footage of him in the flight suit
with the mission accomplished thing or
but evidently that banner got stuck if
they didn't mean Michigan it was pulled
out of spring 2009 but i hope i hope
they run that footage and let's say care
especially if Carrie or Clark is there a
nominee because then this is our answer
this is this this is the ad I got run
the same footage you know one the plane
landing Bush next to the pilot who
landed the plane
Bush gets out start doing that stuff you
know remember the flight suit and with
it remember that codpiece thing he had
on it's not like
let's say it's john kerry here john
kerry say and voiceover while you're
still seeing that here you know dress up
and make believe our fun
but when President Bush George W Bush
had a chance to be a real fighter pilot
in a war he chose instead to let his
daddy get him to the Texas Air National
Guard and then went AWOL for a year
then you cut to a picture of Carrie in
Vietnam says this is me and Vietnam
sorry the picture is so grainy we little
too dangerous to have a lighting crew
come in and you cut to carry in a pirate
suit full pirate suit pic sword you know
the big moustache and the eyepatch the
big hat with the plume and the men a
parrot parrot and he says yep dress up
and make believe our fun but you know we
need a real president who knows how to
create jobs and keep our nation secure
isn't that right PD ah ah that's why
I am so glad you're here you're here
thank you for coming it's going to take
all of us we're gonna need you because
you know what the Republicans want you
to do they want you to shut up shut up
but we're not gonna shut up we're gonna
stand up we're gonna fight and we're
gonna win
I am thank you and one way to do that is
David and Mark Wellstone chose as their
parents legacy wealth Wellstone action
and Wellstone action is training
activists and actually I think there's a
waiting list be trained but if you go to
ww Wellstone org you'll see links to
things that you can do especially in
battleground states like this one and
there's places to go and there's a move
on org and there's things to do sowww
Wellstone org and now i'm going to open
this up to questions and answers and i
think that we have mics in the yes we
have a mic there or you can just raise
your hand i'll repeat your question
actually since we got the c-span thing i
think it's better if people go to the
microphones so there's one down there
and just went down there and you have to
just line up and i'll call on you in the
order that you
yes sir anything in lieu of recent
events would you let your daughter date
Michael Jackson I wouldn't let my son my
daughter I'm no problem with my daughter
he's innocent until proven guilty and
they hope he's innocent it sounds like a
really sad thing yeah speaking of which
you have a question about rush yeah go
ahead I'm sorry Bangladesh and I just
wanted to say that i've been raised by
many proud Americans and I'm really
really overwhelmed by so many real and
proud Americans here today including
yourself I wanted to ask I'm a
journalism major and I know from
experience that predominantly we are
liberals our ideologies are very liberal
why is it that we see so many I mean
Bill O'Reilly and Joe Scarborough's and
you know all these weird people out
there predominantly that's my first part
of the question and secondly do you know
Bengali by any chance I'm wondering what
how you came up with a name for the kid
that you talk about in your book karup
juta yeah um if you don't know carb duta
is the fourteen-year-old Bangladeshi boy
who writes chapter in my book I I point
out in the book that this the liberal
media no major newspaper ever endorsed
or came out against NAFTA or gap and
it's because journalists know that they
can't be replaced by a fourteen-year-old
Bangladeshi boy as many American workers
are and so I conceptually thought well
maybe that's not true in my case and
said that my editor gotta Fort kharap
juta to write a chapter which starts
with work in the factory is very hard
I taught my editor the kid wouldn't be
funny and he wasn't he um I think what
does kharab do to mean cuz I know we
took bangladeshi words oh well it means
bad too bad shoe yeah yeah that's right
yes I am right now I remember thee let's
name them and yeah okay means bad okay
well this issue of why is the media the
way it is and you your experiences that
the students you find it in journalism
are predominantly liberal there is that
argument that they make that journalists
are liberal and you wouldn't know it by
the coverage if you look at the two
thousand race in the way gore was
treated and the way Bush was treated if
you look at the fact the New York Times
broke white water during Clinton I mean
this is the way I put it is that they're
the mainstream media the mainstream
media which is more and more being
consolidated and owned by corp huge
multinational corporations which is one
of the reason a big big big big part of
the reason there are other biases
besides liberal and conservative much
almost more important biases there's
bias toward get it cheap which means
when you cover politics cover horse race
and cover process don't actually discuss
school vouchers just have to pundits who
don't know anything about school
vouchers get you know a little thing
from an intern about school vouchers and
they discuss sensationalist sex I mean
during Monica Lewinsky it was all Monica
all the time for a year and a half there
were some news organizations that did
not succumb to that
I like to cite them wherever I go
sailing magazine
American grocer monthly jugs and big
butt which is ironic I think his big
butt I thought had a story but Fox the
reason you have Fox seems to be working
on cables that's why you have like the
o'reilly imitators and I mean he's very
successful that's why I was sued their
most successful anchor or whatever he is
commentator I wanted them to punish me
and so you know say except he's very
successful and so Scarborough is at
MSNBC and they got rid of Donahue
because he was he was against the war
and they felt they felt brig nervous
about that GE who owns NBC and editors
the people who are at the top of the
food chain in in journalism are
conservative starting with the owners
and working down the editors editors in
this country in two thousand editors
were 22 1444 bush and papers that
endorse Bush had greater circulation
than papers at that endorse Gore you
remember him these the guy who won the
election I can't
but you've obviously read some of the
stuff in my book cuz you got the car up
juta so is it like hopeless like she's
like no no it's not hopeless but I
should I should get to other people
because because this would be a car up
question and answer session by oh thank
you thank you yes hi my name is Gail
Elliot thank you hi I'm glad you talked
about substance and lack of it on the
radio and television and mainstream
media and that's a concern we all share
i'm sure i did a straw poll amongst
friends of mine and really to a person
no one had heard of dennis kucinich is
bill before Congress for a Department of
Peace right and so I'm one very few have
you want to explain it to them do you
have any ideas for getting substantive
information like that could that could
change the course the world out to the
American people short of starting as Al
Gore has suggested an alternative
liberal television channel why trying
with some other people and the other
people are the ones that are really
doing the work form
a a progressive or liberal liberal radio
network where do we sign up work for you
well we're wait to hear the announcement
word you'll have to go to your basements
it's kind of like Radio Free America
chitty-chitty chitty-chitty and again
we're gonna try to do that drug free and
I just I don't know if it's possible and
with compassion I'm sure be adequately
that will and Republican Scott fit like
a Department of Peace that's like isn't
that that's a bad idea is it you know is
that good peace yeah christmas is coming
and isn't that the Prince of Peace they
were supposed to be that no I I do have
a talk a little bit about religion and
there's a chapter called supply-side
Jesus where I talk about greed and and
Christianity but thanks got it this
gentleman yeah my name is Drew I drove
him a recovering Republican oh I'm sorry
thank you welcome welcome
how long has it been
I have been Republican free now for a
little over a year a little over a year
I'll give you a little coin at your next
birthday woohoo my question I consider
myself a pretty average average guy I
read newspapers watch TV listen to the
radio but I don't seem to have a lot of
the information that you were able to
get in your book you know and in other
people I don't have access to those kind
of things why not how how can I get
access to those things that information
so that i can convince my conservative
republican parents just stop well you
gotta you read the British press of
course now um well you know i would i
would like start using your computer a
little bit to chop around for some yeah
just things like you know move on and
slate and I mean slate it isn't
particularly left or right at all but at
least you get started getting links to
things that are provocative and start
telling things that you're not hearing
in in the mainstream press I mean
there's an interesting study done by the
University of Maryland and and I was
just like NPR and and PBS and NPR and
PBS aren't I don't think they're liberal
I but liberals tend to listen to the
more but they did a study on people's
misconceptions about the war in Iraq and
where they got their news and they found
that people who got most of their news
from Fox had were four times as likely
to have certain misperceptions about
like you know such as that we have found
what
tons of mass destruction or that the
majority of the world opinion was for
our invasion and so and one of the
things that he found out was that the
more you watch Fox the more likely you
were happy to have these misperceptions
so in other words more you watch Fox is
stupider you got but on but on that
chain on that chain the people listen to
NPR and got most nuzum and PR and PBS
where the least likely to have these
factual misconceptions and I think it's
you know liberals that people I've heard
this before and I think it's true and I
have to keep this in mind when i do the
rate of network is that liberals like
information and conservatives like
ammunition and they just they just love
to hear the same stuff they think they
know over and over again and so you've
just gotta just go around your you're
buzzflash calm and there's all but look
look in here I site I see well democracy
in half there's kpfk and
they're to lefty for me but but there's
a whole world out there that you can get
access on your on your computer and you
can even get right wing stuff and look
at that mmm that are good conservative
writers David Brooks that's it I can't
right off the top of my back you know
okay head head yes I'm good evening mr.
Franken how are you doing very good
that's good I'm Sylvia Snowden I'm a
sophomore here at the University and I
guess what I'm curious to know is based
on everything that I've seen in the herd
is any Democrat better than no Democrat
at all
yeah yeah I think so um clearly i think
that guy would be worse I yeah
but other than him and then the guy
sitting next to him I yeah good evening
good even thank you for complimenting my
wife earlier this evening in my one of
the book she signed anyway I wanted to
get that through it was a was a
gentlemanly yes oh yeah it's fine right
okay and it'll bring great last for
years to come okay gob my question is
Fox's lawsuit was obviously literally
laughed out of court and I enjoyed
seeing that happen very much this summer
but doesn't Glick have a case against
O'Reilly for defamation and are you in
pursuit or helping him to pursue that in
the okay this is a very good question
because I asked I won't say who the
lawyers where I asked lawyers about this
and they said that he would have to
prove that O'Reilly knew he was lying
did and O'Reilly is so crazy
that O'Reilly could make the case I I I
just thought that he had said that and
so the lawyer's advice to me to then to
Jeremy was stay out of court which I
think it's usually a good idea but this
was really literally to get a defamation
thing part of it has to be done with
malice and has to be done knowing that
you're lying and i really think that he
doesn't know sometimes when he's lying I
actually do think that he could make a
very strong case for the pathological
part obviously see the transcript if he
was doing this week after week after
week yes well I hope now that you know I
ask people at Fox actually tues I made
personal calls to people at Fox to tell
him to stop this and they wouldn't do it
yeah considering how many rumors have
been floating around but your possible
political future if you're planning on
running for congress in the next
election okay well somehow okay in
Newsweek there was a little thing about
the possibility my running in 2008 for
the wellstones seed and I guess the way
the way that kind of came about was that
when I went back I went to do some
Wellstone action events and some people
there asked me and I got to do that and
what one particularly very emotional
event was there was a publishing party
for a book of photos of Paul and Sheila
campaigning in march two and and Paul
was this amazing Lee you know he would
hug you and he literally touch people
his amazing guy and I mean when I say
touch people is not like the Governor of
California
when Paul touch you you didn't feel
humiliated and violating haha and I
guess you know and part of my response
to this whole thing was it you know the
server conservatives have always gone
like how dare Martin Sheen express his
opinions about politics he's an actor
what Susan Sarandon doing telling us her
opinion about things she's an actress
ooh Ahnold running he's the Terminator I
mean you know give me a break I'm trying
to figure out what Arnold's
qualifications were so that I know you
know it's very hard for a movie star to
do in Hollywood is open a restaurant son
of man so I don't know I have you know I
have its 2008 it's a long way away I'd
probably don't have to decide for three
years this is the seat that I would be
interested in to get that seat back I'd
probably have to ask my wife I'm from
Minnesota and I'd have to ask her if she
wanted to move back that's how you stay
married for 28 years is you
my advice do not go back to the state
that you were raised in without
consulting your spouse but in a way I
would be running for office just in
order to spend less time with my family
I know usually in see how that way but
there are a lot of things I really care
about and I think that the senator who's
there now who ran a campaign against
Paul that I I didn't like I thought they
were in a very dirty campaign is pretty
much just doing the president's bidding
and I think there's just a lot of things
you can do in the Senate I don't know if
I'd be the best candidate and so I'm
considering it but if I do you guys will
be the first to know but just not true
yes sir well actually I was going to ask
the Wellstone question but I have
another one now they're talking possibly
of drafting Hillary Clinton for the 2004
what do you think about that isn't going
to happen when one of these nine people
running is going to and Hillary cannot
run in 2004 she promised not to run in
2004 and it was just see daddy would
just confirm all the worst things they
say about her so she can't do it and
she's not going to I told hilary that
she should just like go to New Hampshire
to make an announcement and get everyone
all excited and just say I'm not running
haha so you're Republicans can stop
raising money by saying I'm running so
she says she said they just raised it
anyway that would work yes sir um a few
minutes ago you mentioned actors who run
for office and as a political scientist
I was wondering your
thoughts on the Republicans push to
idolize or cement Ronald Reagan's legacy
given I mean he was such a great policy
maker no really well so I was wondering
what your thoughts were on that given
his policy especially let's talk about
for example the CBS movie I am probably
the only liberal who I think CBS blew it
from the moment they started that
project to do a movie on Reagan and
concentrate on that relationship when he
is when he has Alzheimer's and she is
taken care of I think is is problematic
I think that if you're going to do a
movie about Reagan you do it about the
fact that he prayed the Lark this huge
deficit that he armed the Mujahideen
that he armed Saddam that he armed Iran
he armed two-thirds of the axis of evil
he you know he funded terrorists in
Central America he was in my mind a
terrible president
but
but that's the movie to do the movie to
do isn't the relationship between the
two of them when when anyone who's and I
haven't but gone through the Fed
experience of treating someone with
Alzheimer's and she's very dedicated to
him i think it was and of getting a
playwright to put lines in his mouth
that he didn't say i think the public
record is fine on it and i know that
when you do a doctor drama you have to
write the scenes that where people
weren't so i know that's a problem and I
think the doc I'm sure look if they took
every lousy TV show off the air there'd
be just a lot of dead air so and i have
also i would within a defense of CBS and
of the playwright and whoever wrote this
thing I haven't seen it so I would
reserve judgment before seeing it but I
know everyone is like saying how can see
V has caved all this stuff I think they
they had a problem and I'm not outraged
that they pulled it I I'm not I you know
that it was a cheesy docudrama but it is
a dangerous thing when when the right
can start dictating what's on and what
isn't so there's a lot of issues there
but i think that the someone should
really do what the leg and reagan legacy
really is and we'll have to wait to see
that yes mr. frank and has a law student
here and as a coastal liberation radio I
just want to thank you for all the
quotes I'm gonna steal from you later on
and say they were mine and I'm gonna
steal anything from the book have a
two-point question with reason very good
stolen a lot already but uh okay good
very very easy questions first I keep on
hearing about a fight with sean hannity
that's one and two how do you feel about
the drug war okay I Sean Han I wouldn't
fight sean hannity I think I think he
beat me up
hahahaha me too he's younger I
challenged rich Lowry to a fight and
that's the and him I could be him up
which is part of the reason I challenged
him to a fight I he had as a chapter in
the book and he had gone on c-span and
said that liberals had feminized
politics and had sissified politics and
so I called him the next day and I said
I saw UNC's been say that you want to
fight and he said what and I said you
want to fight I said where where would
we fight i said i don't know in my
parking garage actually he said he said
you do you fight a lot do you have you I
said no I've never had a fight I've
never had a fight but I figured that if
someone says that Democrats have
sissified politics that they can't turn
down a fight and I wrestled in high
school and I I you know 50 years old and
I have a bad back but I think I could
kick your ass hey said he said what are
the rules i said no rules is like fight
club there's no rules you know I just
you know first one to say uncle gives a
thousand dollars the other guys charity
so and he said well can I think about it
and I said sure and and he declined but
i don't think i'd fight hannity i think
that'd be a good it'd be a good fight
but that way but i don't i don't want to
be in a fight i mean it's just I just I
thought two things he said Democrats at
sissified politics and I sized him up
and felt that I could take him I told my
son I told and I write this in the bud I
told my son about this and he went on
dad you know and then and then rich
happened to being riches as these
conservatives ago I'd have don't he's
not as bad and some and he was like a
regular on McNiel error for a while and
he was on or on what I call making all
eras the newshour with jim allure and he
and jim he was on and i called my son
said Joe the guy I was gonna I
challenged with fights on and he runs in
and the camera switch to Lera and and my
son said dad he's like 70 years old I
said no not him the other the other guy
here here here and he goes it's like oh
well God dad you know he's such a wimp
so but I don't think he'd want me any
trouble what Anna drug Allah how do you
spell drug work drug war probably a more
important question
well you know as Rush Limbaugh said that
anyone who uses drugs illegally should
be prosecuted and put away
I don't agree with them I think they
should be treated but that's what Rush
believes and so as you know what we're
praying for rush and that you know that
he's in recovery and as you know in
recovery you take responsibility for
your actions so I'm sure that rush any
day now well if the allegations are true
that he took drugs illegally which I
guess he'd have to to be addicted the
way he was that he will ask not a demand
to be put away for the maximum maximum
sentence and put in an ass for the most
dangerous prison where we're praying for
him that he'll be in a cell with maybe
an african-american cellmate who saw the
donovan mcnabb comments yes can't that
were so we're praying we're praying for
me yes hi all my name is Janet and I'm a
high school English teacher as well as a
mother to two teenagers and I brought my
17 year old son with me tonight as whose
birthday present and I was wondering if
you or Stewart smiley would have some
words of wisdom or advice to give to him
this evening for real okay um well I
don't know if Stewart's even here let me
look well you look for me he's here okay
okay um say I'm a little nervous I
haven't been this nervous since I was
had to speak at the national shame
conference okay so what's what's your
name Chris okay let's still let's do an
information
Chris up close your eyes don't look at
me only you can help you go to the
microphone with your mother is so we can
hear you it close your eyes oh ok say
hello me hello me I am a Democrat
did you say it say it again I am a
Democrat I am fun to be with I am I am
fun to be with because I'm good enough
because I'm good enough I'm smart enough
I'm smart enough and doggone it we're
gonna beat bush and doggone it we're
gonna beat us
happy birthday Kris happy birthday
that's a that's a misuse of stewarts
stewarts very apolitical although i
Mahatma Gandhi Stuart's one of Stewart's
heroes old cuz Stewart heard he had an
eating disorder I don't know what that
joke beans go ahead I mr. Frank and I'm
Derek schnell end up my shirts a bit of
kidding on the square here ah yes
getting on the square is a phrase
entranc thank you trying to get into the
vernacular it means yes as I'm
Republican and I'm I'm okay and I'm okay
and he's just kidding I'm not sure
that's getting on the square but go
ahead okay I wanted to ask you looking
back at the two thousand election
especially the coverage of it how do you
think it's gonna be different in 2004
and how do you think it should be
different in 2004 boy it's a good
question a tough question in two
thousand you know I don't know if it's
going to be any different the problem is
is that as I say the the networks tend
to give less and less time to politics
they get they include less and less of
the stump speeches they spend less and
less time on policy I just hope that I
think that after nine eleven the press
in this country's their testicles just
shriveled up and went into their body
cavities
with a slurping sound and and they
haven't descended yet and I mean for
example when Bob Novak ran that piece
about where to top Republican
administration officials outed as CIA
agent this is in July where were
Woodward and Bernstein I mean what
happened nothing we heard almost nothing
about it until the FBI announced it was
doing an investigation then we've heard
very little bit about it since can you
imagine Clinton the Clinton
administration had outed a CIA operative
this is Joseph Wilson's wife Joseph
Wilson is the guy the Ambassador who
went Tunisia air to check on the
document that said that Iraq had tried
to buy uranium from these year and he
came back and told the CIA that there
was it wasn't true and there's nothing
to it and the CIA told the White House
then ended up in the state of the union
address and they had they had taken out
of the Cincinnati address when he told
the country why we were going to war but
they showed up again in the in save you
a dress and kind of leads a rife that's
why after the CIA asked him to take it
out and Cincinnati White was in the save
you need rest and she said well we
forgot so Joseph Joseph Wilson writes an
hour an op-ed piece in New York Times
and someone in the administration top
administration officials according to
Bob Novak and call him and like six
other or five other journalists two out
Joseph Wilson's wife who is a CIA
operative in weapons of mass destruction
they're willing to you know sacrifice a
national security asset to
punish Joseph Wilson it was revenge and
if the glendon people have done this the
press have been all over and I don't get
it I just don't get it so that's
listen it is almost ten o'clock or am i
on eastern time I don't know but I think
we've gone about almost two how long are
we almost two hours we could go on
forever but that wasn't enthusiastic
enough so I should have cut it off with
the Stuart Smalley my show biz instinct
and I think that what let's let's see
how just asked me to do another
affirmation would you no no I'm okay
what's your question I was wondering if
it would be possible to have if you
think would be possible to have a
successful Liberal talk show host
without being on Clear Channel stations
and you think clear channel might be
trying to suppress someone in that
situation clear channel says that they
you know are just in it for profit and I
believe them and that although the
people like Hicks a guy runs clear
channel is a crony of bushes and I'm not
so sure about that I think that the
reason that i'm talking about creating a
liberal talk network is the landscape of
talk radio is so conservative that by
definition if i were to do a radio show
on a talk radio any talking radio
stations country i would be between they
have to go after rush and then to be
handy or a Riley or I mean and radio is
really about is about format and it
would be like putting hip hop after
country-western and i'm not sure the
people would stay tuned after listening
to rush to me or vice versa so I this is
this is at least the theory that we're
operating under and trying to put this
liberal network together so that's why
we're doing that
yes son all right I know I'm probably
not the best guy to be addressing this
I'm only 14 but I want to cite the
return of one of my favorite well my
favorite chapters from Rush Limbaugh's a
big fat idiot operation Chicken Hawk
yeah which I found very funny in rush
limbaugh is a big fat idiot thank you
for signing both of these by the way and
I want to get you know i'm pretty sure
you touched on this but i want to get
your feelings on these Republicans who
are trying to sell themselves off as war
heroes when they ins you know they
themselves chickened out nom well that's
the point of operation Chicken Hawk in
operation Chicken Hawk i created this
platoon of chicken Hawks which are
Russian gingrich and phil gramm and all
these let's see dan quayle bap you can
and just any of them just you know throw
a stone at the Republican caucus and
you'll hit a Chicken Hawk you know and
put them in a platoon in the first one
put them in platoon where Olly North
tries to get them to fight and they
won't they just won't do it and in this
one I have them on I have ash Croft and
O'Reilly and two who died put in this
unit uh-huh but yes of course Bush and
Cheney bush and trained and Cheney on on
carries swift boat and their mission is
to go up river and extract the other the
chickenhawks from the last one
because there they've been fraggin all
their lieutenants and and officers and
they're just they you know the brass
just wants them out and it's just going
to give my honorable discharges and get
them out of Vietnam so that's what what
this episode is about and it's it's a
prequel actually to the first one
because I've been studying Star Wars it
seems to work well as I'm gonna anyone
who has a question I'm gonna have I'm
going to do some more signing and anyone
has a question you can ask me I'm here i
don't i'm not leaving missouri tonight
so I but I just feel like this has been
you know it's about the right length of
an evening have you had a nice time
sorry estaba do
well thank you very much I will talk to
anyone who wants to talk to me thank you
we need all of you stand up and fight
thank you good night
we had originally planned to pair this
program with Bill O'Reilly talking about
his book who's looking out for you
however mr. O'Reilly refused to allow
book TV cameras into his recent event in
Long Island al franken's book lies in
the lying liars who tell them is
published by penguin putnam online at
penguin putnam calm